foreign
Phoenix what's up Kim
hey good morning good morning
what are you up to
um working oh don't do that
I know but it's Friday yay way to go
what's up
hey um so my question is uh I have a son
who he's an adult
um about 27 and he is really overweight
um and I'm concerned about his
well-being not only
his his weight but also I think it's
just a symptom of depression for him and
I don't really know how to talk to him
about it without alienating him or
feeling like he's being judged
um
and I I really I just I want to help
them I but I realize he's not a little
boy anymore and I can't but you know I
can't just throw him in the car and take
him to the doctor
um
how long has he struggle with his weight
a kid but he he was always like a big
boy right so always like Stout
um I'd say the the weight really just
kind of compounded probably within the
last 10 years or so okay what um
what in the environment
or let me just cut to the chase have you
struggled with your weight
um his dad struggled his weight other
people in the family
um
um I mean yes but not
like not like he has I mean was there a
culture of dieting was everybody on a
diet back in the day
um well yes okay okay
um nothing to feel shame about there I'm
just trying to get a context here
um Okay so
foreign
there's so much there I can look at the
data that says that a number of obese
there's a correlation or uh I'll say not
causable correlation between childhood
abuse and obesity there is genetics and
obesity there is environmental and
obesity right there's so many different
things and so anytime I'm on the
internet and somebody on Instagram's
like here's the deal I was whatever man
and then there's also the biomechanics
there's there's uh energy expenditure
right
you take in uh more than you I mean less
than you use then you lose weight you
take it more than you use and you gain
weight so it's the whole picture is Big
um no no pun intended there
um the whole picture is just it's vast
right and so
um here's what I did I I got a note from
Jenna that this was that you were
calling and so I actually called a
friend who's
done some extraordinary work
um is down a whole bunch of weight
really impressive actually motivated me
to get my butt back in the gym in a way
that was useful and
um so I asked him hey how would you like
to have had this conversation
um
and he gave me some really helpful
insights that were that were
different than what I thought quite
honestly so before I kind of write all
those off walk me through how other
conversations similar have gone with you
and him
having a conversation with him
specifically about his weight what about
what about others there's something
about you having a hard conversation
where you tell them you love him and
that you don't think is going to go well
because he shuts down and then he he
tends to ghost me
um
[Music]
here's where I'm here's where I'm I'm
stutter stepping is I want to ask you
his mom some relationship questions but
you have to promise me you're not gonna
hang up the phone and beat yourself up
and be all and feel guilty and all that
I want to be more about let's get to the
solution Focus part of this thing
um but often when I ask Moms especially
hard questions and sometimes dads it
just turns into a shame Factory and I
don't want to do that is that okay
oh yeah that's fine okay I'm good do you
all have a history of you telling him
about his you know what you need to do
you need to because that often causes
the shutdown
I do okay yeah
okay give me an example of a thing
you've got after him about and he just
shuts it down
um well
a couple weeks ago we
and
um we had a nice lunch together and we
talked and
he had opened up about some of the way
that he was feeling and um I suggested I
made some suggestions of him just you
know taking some small steps and hey I
joined the gym that's really close to my
where you live and if you would like to
meet me there after work I'd love to
walk with you or I'll even put you on my
gym membership but you just need to do
something like every day and get up and
you know go do that and so yeah you know
he's and he's been on other diets before
like
going spending money on like weight loss
um centers and going and he's had some
luck but
I admit you know we've been a little
negative about that because we just
didn't think it was the right approach
or sustainable
um so I mean I feel guilty about that
because it should have just supported
him in whatever but I
um
so so so I agree with you I agree with
you
um
foreign
hey I've recognized I've put on a lot of
weight I'm not healthy anymore and again
let's get away from the
um the body positivities I'm talking
about just Health he's not healthy he
doesn't feel good and he knows it and
you know everybody knows it
um if he comes to you and says hey
what's the best plan do you think for me
what's the best plan for you
um then that's an invitation to say well
here's what I've seen be successful
here's what I've tried a couple of times
it hasn't worked when you launch
missiles at him of well here's what you
need to be doing
yes that is I mean all you can do is put
up your force field right you put up
your defense shields
and he's learned that over his entire
life and my guess is he's seen Mom and
or dad on diets for most of their life
and he's seen them be miserable
and I don't want any part of that and I
don't want any part of my
um increasing
um unhealthy behaviors
and the only solution I have for that
being stuck in the middle there is to
eat
see what I'm saying see how he's trapped
yeah okay so here's the here's what I
would do in this situation and I'm gonna
start it with this
um
I saw a clip years ago it might have
been 10 years ago and it has resonated
with me just stuck with me it was pin or
teller do you know which one pin or
teller the tall one
that's uh pen pin that's all yeah all
right so pin um just had like was
talking into a cell phone this is before
Instagram it was all pretty and slick
and everything it was just him and this
if the phone was too close to his face I
remember and here's what he said uh pin
is a is a is a very vocal atheist and
um
but all accounts are really kind human
being just a very vocal atheist and he
said after a show
um he's recording this right after this
interaction after a show some fans came
and they were talking about you know the
show and how much they liked it and then
one fan in particular was very
knowledgeable about magic was mesmerized
by the interaction was really talk like
he said this guy knew what he was
talking about and I loved the
interaction with him he clearly loved
the show and he clearly was moved by our
performance and how much fun it was and
all that stuff
and then he said as the guy was leaving
he turned and said hey I I know your
beliefs and thoughts I just can't walk
away without letting you know I'd love
for you to come to church with me
tomorrow or the next whenever it was and
um it'd be awesome you'd be my guest and
they shook hands and he left and here's
what Penn said he said if you ever want
to try to convict somebody that's how
you do it
through relationship through genuine
conversation and he said that man
um he said if if a truck is driving down
the street and you're in the middle of
the street
you have to push the guy out of the way
and he said after talking with that man
for a while
he believes I'm in the middle of a
street and a truck is barreling down on
me and he wants me to be okay forever
and he says I disagree with him I don't
believe what he's saying but man I
really am grateful for the way he
reached out to try to love me a little
bit better
and so I tell you that to tell you he
didn't walk around and hold signs in
front of the show
he didn't lob grenades throughout the
show
he went up and shook his hand and said
you're amazing at your craft can we talk
craft for a minute because I want to be
a magician too and by the way I need you
to know I love you do you see the
difference there
yes okay so I'm a huge fan of if you
love somebody you have the hard
conversation I'm also a big fan of if
you think somebody is In Harm's Way you
tell them
I'm also a big fan of whenever possible
do it out of relationship and you might
have to submit to the fact that you
might not be the right person to have
this conversation
there might be too much baggage in the
past so here's how I would approach this
if I were you and this is my kid number
one I would probably have some sort of
lunch meeting again and say I have
absolutely blown this whole thing and
I'm sorry I screwed this up I'm always
lecturing you treating you like you're
12 and you're a grown adult and I'm
sorry I love you and I don't know how to
do this but it's the first time I've had
a son like this so I don't know how to
do it and I just want you to know I'm
sorry I should have supported you I
should have been all behind who wants to
go work out with her mom
uh nobody nobody
um so just just just lay it out and he
might be stunned this might be so
opposite of the way you normally
interact in the world
um you might have to practice this a few
times but just tell him
um there is not a thing on Earth you can
do that will make me love you less
period
and then let him know this
when and if you ever want to have this
conversation with me I'm willing to put
money on the table I'm going to be
supportive and keep my mouth shut I'm
going to love you but I want you to know
I'm worried about your health and I love
you forever to the Moon and back
and then here's part two
um my friend told me that yes his mom's
had conversations with him for years but
it was actually a mentor it was a buddy
that reached out out of the blue and had
um invited him into a solution
said hey I just want you to know this is
a hard conversation and I'm just I don't
want to be weird but I want you to know
that I love you and I'm worried about
you and that combined with Mom's support
um was a game changer
and it reminded me when he was telling
me of this when I was in the throes of
being anxious like a crazy person
my wife actually reached out to my
friend Todd
who is a banker a stogo I've talked
about him on the show
um he's the one who drove down and met
with me and walked around the house when
I was showing him how the house was
falling in and he's the one that said
stop
we're done with all of this you got to
get the help
and because I couldn't hear it from
myself anymore I couldn't hear it from
my wife anymore I couldn't hear it from
my parents anymore
but listening to Todd that was the first
time I looked in the mirror and said it
may be me I need to go talk to somebody
and so if he has a friend if he has a
male Mentor if he's got some men in his
life that he trusts and you want to do
an end around and call one of them and
say hey would you mind reaching out and
just tell them that you love him that
you're worried about him
um I think that would go a long long way
what do you think about all that
I think it's
um
I think it's wise advice like
um how old is he
he's 27. okay can we admit something
the way you've done it up till now
hasn't worked
because I hear the hesitancy will you
try something else
yes yes okay I promise you that nobody
on Earth knows that he's overweight more
than he does
is that true
so let's be with not at right now
okay
okay
tell me why you're crying
worry yeah
because you love him
yes
foreign
and this happens at the at the at the
national level
happens at the state level happens the
neighborhood level happens in our homes
happens in our marriages happens with
our kids
sometimes we love so much and we're out
of we're out of uh
we're out of
tools
all we have in our in our bag is a
hammer
so instead of we're just hit start
hitting the nail and hitting the nail
and hitting the nail and it's not moving
and so we just start wailing at it
because oh we only know one thing to do
and that's just to swing the hammer
harder instead of putting the hammer
down and saying okay that's not working
I need to go think on something else
I know you love him I know you love him
a lot
let's focus on being with not at let's
focus on getting some people that he
listens to in his life and that means
you have to admit that it may not be you
let's get some people in his life and
let's be about forgiving yourself
again I don't want you hanging up the
phone and beating yourself up Kim okay
we do the best we can because we love
our kids
and it's also important when we realize
I need to call somebody else
let him know from this point forward I'm
not gonna throw a bunch of advice at you
I'm not going to throw all my diet books
and my apps and my gym memberships at
you
you don't have to put on leg warmers and
come work out with your mind with your
mom
I'm worried about you and I love you and
I will be in your corner
unfortunately sometimes that's the best
we can do
thank you for loving him